[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american
biographical comedy drama film called
green book spoilers ahead watch out and
take care
the premise of the movie is set in the
year 1962
an italian-american doorman tony works
at the copacabana nightclub in the bronx
he frequently comes across rude
customers on his job but is not afraid
to throw hands when they break the
club's code one day a wealthy
businessman visits their club and
emphasizes that his hat must be kept
safe since it was a gift from his mother
tony steals the hat which makes the
businessman go ballistic on the staff
later he gives it back pretending to
have recovered it from a thief because
of the gesture he not only gets money
from the businessman but also befriends
him tony and his friends are distressed
because for the next two months the club
is being closed for renovation they have
to look for a part-time job to keep
their families fed the following day two
african-american men come to repair the
kitchen sink at tony's house since it is
the 1960s the african-american
population in the u.s is a frequent
target of racism dolores though doesn't
care about their race and is very
welcoming she even offers them water and
sees them off politely however after
they leave tony throws away the glasses
they drank from he doesn't think much of
it because such subtle but apparent
racist behavior is common in society at
this time one day while tony is still
looking for a job he gets a call from an
associate of his the person tells him
about someone named dr don shirley who
is looking for a driver the very next
day tony goes to don's place for an
interview and finds out that he is an
african-american man he has a doctorate
in psychology and music and is a world
famous pianist tony has never seen such
a luxurious lifestyle in his entire life
and to think that it all belongs to dawn
is surprising to him the pianist is
planning to go on an eight-week concert
tour through the midwest and deep south
and needs don to be his driver for the
trip if everything goes well they will
be able to return home on christmas eve
don explains the job to tony who is
unwilling to be his butler alongside his
driver don increases the pay because he
knows that he's going to face extreme
racism on the trip and tony seems like
someone who can protect him but tony
refuses and walks away later that day
the pianist calls tony's home and asks
dolores for permission to take her
husband away for two months tony agrees
to accompany him for 125 dollars a week
and remember in the 60s you could have
bought some pretty sweet nfts with that
money on the day of their departure
dolores wishes him farewell and urges
him to write letters throughout the trip
the record company rents them a nice car
and informs tony that if he misses a
show he will only get half the money
more importantly they provide him with
something called the green book it is a
tourist guide for black people in
america that consists of a list of safe
places for them to stay in the
segregated southern states tony is
surprised that something like this book
even exists the journey starts and
initially tony bores dawn with his
non-stop chatter don is also especially
annoyed because of tony's improper
grammar usage and absurd vocabulary his
habit of eating messily with his hands
and taking a leak in the middle of the
road all seem outrageous to him with his
first show dawn impresses everyone
including tony with his brilliant
performance tony immediately starts to
respect him as a musician later he is
caught gambling with the helpers while
waiting for the show to end don stops
him disappointed that he chose to come
outside when he had the option to take
the high road and stay at the party as
the journey continues tony plays
contemporary music on the radio he is
shocked to find out that don doesn't
know popular musicians like aretha
franklin since she is especially famous
among the african-american community he
is even more surprised when don reveals
that he has never had kentucky fried
chicken they stop at the original
restaurant in kentucky and tony forces
dawn to try some although he is
initially skeptical about eating with
his hands he is pleasantly surprised
upon trying the dish one day they stop
at a gas station where tony finds an
expensive jade gemstone on the ground
that seems to have fallen off a cart of
a rock seller he pockets it but is
immediately called out by dawn the
pianist asks him to go inside and pay
for the rock this instant tony whines
and groans but does it anyway
then the duo reaches the second venue
where the grand piano for dawn is not
cleaned the janitor claims that a black
person like him would have no problem
playing on such a piano the comment
makes tony furious and he punches the
man in the face the piano is then
cleaned and polished for the performance
as they head further south don is made
to stay at blacks only hotels even
though he is among his people he doesn't
seem at home one night he goes to a bar
where a bunch of racists beat him up
just for being there tony quickly rushes
to the location and threatens the thugs
claiming that he has a gun after they
narrowly escape the encounter don asks
him if he really has a gun tony replies
that he was just bluffing and the two
continue to the hotel for the next
concert they stop at a southern mansion
as usual dawn is the center of
attraction in the room and is respected
by all he is also the only
african-american man other than the
butlers but he is used to such an
environment the host even makes special
fried chicken for the main guest but
during intermission he is barred from
using the white people's bathroom the
host directs him to a tiny cubicle made
of wood outside the house refusing to be
humiliated don returns to the hotel to
go to the bathroom before going back to
the concert tony is furious at seeing
don being polite to the people who
denied him basic decency throughout the
journey tony writes letters to dolores
but they are mostly awful dawn reads
them and sees several spelling mistakes
and grammar blunders he helps tony make
them more poetic and beautiful back in
new york dolores gets the letter and
cannot help but cry because she cannot
believe tony is literate also because
it's beautiful in the following scene
the duo is walking down to their next
destination when they spot a handsome
suit displayed in the front of a store
don walks in to buy it but the owner
refuses to let him try it on before
paying because none of the other
customers are required to do the same it
is clear that the man is judging him on
the basis of his skin color tony tries
to retaliate but don stops him and
politely leaves that evening tony gets a
call from the police station calling him
in urgently he goes there to see don and
a man naked in a cell it turns out that
they were caught engaging in homosexual
intimacy tony bribes the officers to let
don go which he is not very happy about
he claims that the cops were wrong in
this situation which makes him wrong for
supporting them tony on the other hand
calls him ungrateful in the following
scene the duo is outside a hotel when
tony runs into two of his italian
friends from new york seeing that he is
working for an african-american man they
ask him to have some dignity he has even
offered a job with better pay later that
day don offers tony double the money and
promotes him to his travel manager he
speaks italian revealing that he
understood everything his friends talked
about earlier tony reveals that he was
never planning to leave him in the
middle of the concert and refuses to
accept more money don is visibly touched
by this comment on the way to their
final show in mississippi the duo is
pulled over by the local police it turns
out that in their part of town
african-american people are restricted
from being out past sundown the officer
pulls them out of the car and calls tony
a racial slur for being an italian he
loses his temper and punches the officer
eventually leading them to being
arrested don uses his rights to call
someone from the station in a short time
the police receive an angry call from
the governor they eventually have to
release don and tony because of dawn's
influence outside dawn reveals that he
called the u.s attorney general robert
kennedy tony is amazed and happy about
the experience but don doesn't feel the
same he is furious at tony since now
they'll be late for the last show he has
been called names his entire life and is
mad that tony couldn't even handle it
once the conversation turns into an
argument when tony calls don a
delusional rich man who doesn't know
anything about the struggles his own
people have to face don storms out of
the car in frustration his entire life
he has been too black for white people
too white for black people and not man
enough for being a homosexual he
expresses his frustration to don who
understands his problems and silently
apologizes that night they stay at a
hotel where tony writes yet another
letter to his wife he claims that he has
gotten the hang of it by now but don
insists on reading it in the letter tony
has described his wife as a house full
of a happy family the pianist smiles and
approves of it a few hours later they
arrive at the final concert venue in
alabama don is shown great respect when
the host lets him park his car in the
space that he calls the guest of honor
spot but right after he is taken to a
tiny closet that is his dressing room
don doesn't complain and continues
changing inside of it he then tries to
join the others in the dining room but
is denied access the host claims that
they have nothing personal against him
but it has been a tradition for the
restaurant to only allow black's
servants to walk inside the dining space
when don refuses to play unless he is
allowed to dine the host tries bribing
tony to persuade his boss tony is about
to get handsy with the man but don stops
him he gives tony the right to choose
what he should do eat somewhere else and
continue the show or ditch it all
together tony chooses the latter and
they drive off to a bar for black people
don flashes his wallet filled with money
which a couple of thugs notice he even
plays the piano with the local jazz band
and enjoys his time to the fullest when
they're about to leave tony spots the
thugs from earlier waiting behind their
car to mug them he uses his gun to fire
two shots into the air and scare them
away from behind him a shocked don
swears that he knew tony had a gun all
along the duo then begins their journey
back to new york hoping to make it by
christmas eve they drive through a
snowstorm that makes the journey even
more difficult dawn jokingly asks tony
to bring his lucky stone out because
they need it for the ride tony
shamelessly puts the stone that he stole
on the dashboard and the two laugh about
it after hours of driving non-stop tony
can no longer stay awake he gives up on
reaching home by christmas eve but don
offers to drive while he rests in the
back seat they make it to tony's
apartment just before the family dinner
tony invites dawn in but he wishes them
merry christmas and drives away dolores
and the family are pleasantly surprised
to have him back as they talk about the
trip tony's brother jokingly calls dawn
a slur but a changed tony asks him to be
more respectful hey don't you dare call
me a gobble goo a while later a knock on
the door reveals that don has returned
to join them the entire family welcomes
him wholeheartedly dolores hugs him and
thanks him for helping tony with his
letters in the last clip a picture of
real life tony is shown he continued
working at the copacabana and became the
maitre d of the club don also continued
his music career and was highly
successful they remained friends for the
rest of their lives before they both
passed away in 2013
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching